Film Courage: Ten years ago I believe you
visit The Cat House of the Kings
Jack Perez, Writer/Director: The Cat House
on the Kings, yes.
Film Courage: Cat House on the Kings, sorry.
So how did this wonderful sanctuary change
your life?
Jack: Oh it was huge!
You know we’ve talked about this…we had
a feral cat.
We’ve always had feral cats come to our
house because we have lots of cats.
And a feral cat (a wild cat) will sense that
cat people live there.
And a feral cat obviously cannot be pet or
touched or anything (they are wild animals).
But we’ve done this over the years and we’ve
fed feral cats.
So I guess it was a little over ten years
ago we were moving from out apartment and
just as we were about to move a feral cat
showed up and it was like “feed me.”
And we were like “Yes, of course we’ll
feed you, but we’re moving.”
And we were faced with this prospect of like
“What are we going to do?
This animal is dependent upon us now but we’re
moving.”
It got to the point where I was literally
driving across town every day to leave food
at this empty house.
This cat was standing there (it was the saddest
thing).
It was like “Where’s my food?”
I’m driving across town, I can’t keep
this up.
I can’t expect the new tenants to take care
of him or whatever.
So I started looking into resumes and looking
into that whole world and I became educated.
I was like “Wow?
There are just tons of kill shelters.
If you bring an animal to a regular shelter,
they will be killed.
Certainly a feral can never be adopted (rarely).
What do you do with a feral cat?
And so after a lot of research I found this
one place which I had never heard of The Cat
House on the Kings which was this one woman’s
massive property up near Fresno which she
had turned into this ranch style multi acre
property into this sanctuary and adoption
center where she had almost a thousand animals
that were totally cared for (it wasn’t a
hoarder) it was like an operation.
And she was like “Yeah, we actually have
a feral section and if you can catch him,
you can bring him here.”
And everybody else was like “We’re full
up and they’ll kill them.”
And this was the one place.
And when I went up there it was like one woman
and one other person (or a couple) and all
of these animals and I was like the definition
to me of like a saint.
This was like this woman who had dedicated
her whole life to these animals (literally)
and it was like making it work.
She definitely needed help.
And I said to myself “My God, what can I
do in exchange for this?
You saved this cat’s life and these thousands
of other dogs and cats.
So I decided to make this Youtube video.
I said “I’ll come back and do a portrait
of you and the place, a couple of minutes
and we’ll put it on Youtube.”
And this was when Youtube was sort of new
and just as when luck would have it there
were enough cat people out there that it started
to go viral and people really saw that this
was this beautiful soul that was doing something
so unique and she started to get donations
and she started to get more well known.
And now (10-13 years later) it’s considered…it’s
a very well-known institution around the world.
People come from all over the world to visit
this place and support it.
So it’s a big part of SEARCH & RESCUE’s
story.
The ending of the whole movie actually happens
at the Cat House, actually takes place at
the Cat House.
And I’m trying to talk Lynea Lattanzio (the
proprietor) into actually playing herself
in the movie if she’ll agree to do it because
she’s such a character.
But yes the whole movie actually resolves
at The Cat House.
Film Courage: Had you thought about what would
have happened if you had moved one week earlier
and never met that one cat?
Jack: I hadn’t really thought about that?
It’s been such a…my wife has said “It’s
the most important film you’ve ever made
was that film for The Cat House because (talking
about direct action) that film because it
went viral, because I made it, because it
exists and it reached people, that institution,
that sanctuary received much-needed donations
that saved a lot more animals.
And so in terms of doing something that is
valuable (truly valuable) that little film
when I think about it was that little film
is definitely up there in being an important
movie of mine because it helped, it ultimately
helped a lot of animals.
Film Courage: Do you know how many views that
video has?
Jack: Well I think know it’s well over a
million views.
But conversely I did this fun monster thing
for Youtube years ago (Fear Force 5), that
has 50 million views now.
But the million and a half or whatever The
Cat House has is way more valuable because
that just means something in real world terms.
There were a lot of animals that got saved
because people gave because they saw the video.
So I don’t know what would have happened.
Certainly SEARCH & RESCUE wouldn’t have
evolved the way that it did because there
is a cat component, a feral component and
a rescue component to the story that is a
thread in this crime story that is a direct
result of my experience with The Cat House
on the Kings and why I feel it’s appropriate
to end the movie there even though there are
gangsters and assassins and peddlers
and all this other stuff in the movie, it
ultimately ends at The Cat House which is
like the sweetest place on earth.
Check out Jack’s video on The Cat House
on the Kings (link in description)